A LOT OF INTERESTING THINGS
FROM THE COMBINE LAST NIGHT,
RICH WAS FRONT AND CENTER WITH
HIS BUDDY. DANIEL JEREMIAH
HE JOINS US NOW
FROM INDIANAPOLIS TO TELL US
ALL ABOUT IT.
WELL COME TO YOUR SHOW RICH.
HOW WE DOING?
WELCOME TO YOU, WHATEVER RICH.
HOW ARE YOU? WE'RE GOOD. WE'RE
GOOD.
GIG LAST NIGHT RADIO
CRITIQUING THE QUARTERBACKS IN
EVERYTHING. THAT'S WHY I HAD
IT ON MUTE, BUT FRIEND
OF MINE AND RUPERT. LAUGHS
SAID YOU GAVE ME A LITTLE
SHOUT OUT THERE ABOUT ABOUT MY
LIKE FOR CARSON STRONG. YEAH,
MAN. THANK YOU,
OF COURSE. AND AND
BOY, HE'S HE'S,
HIS LAST NAME IS APPROPRIATE.
YEAH, THAT'S, THAT'S A GOOD
POINT.
YOU CAN BRING IT, MAN.
YOU CAN THROW IT. HE CAN THROW
LIKE NOBODY ELSE'S BUSINESS.
WHAT WAS YOUR BIGGEST
TAKEAWAY? WE HAVE A LOT OF YOU
KNOW THINGS TO TALK ABOUT WITH
YOU FROM THE COME BY, BUT WAS
YOUR BIGGEST TAKEAWAY COVERING
IT FROM FROM BEGINNING TO END
WITH THE WITH THE WIDE OUTS
AND QUARTERBACKS LAST NIGHT.
WELL,
I THINK
GET ANOTHER
DRAFT WHERE
THE WIDE RECEIVER POSITION.
WE'LL JUST
KEEPS TALKING UP
TEAMS WITH ONE AFTER ANOTHER,
AFTER ANOTHER
OF KIDS THAT CAN REALLY
GAME. I MEAN, THE LAST TWO
YEARS,
YOU'VE SEEN A ROOKIE
RECEIVER FROM LSU.
COME IN AND TRANSFORM.
AN OFFENSE
SAID THAT HE JOINS AND
YOU KNOW,
YOU'D BE HARD-PRESSED TO SIT
HERE AND SAY THAT
SOMEBODY THAT WE SAW LAST
NIGHT WON'T WON'T DO THE SAME.
I MEAN, THEY'RE ALL REALLY,
REALLY GOOD AND THEY WERE THEY
THEY CAUGHT THE BALL. WELL,
THEY RAN
VERY WELL.
AND OLAVE AND
SEEING THEM WITH MY OWN TWO
REALLY.
WAS AMAZING.
I THOUGHT THE
WIDE RECEIVER POSITION IS
STOPPED AND I'M NOT SURPRISED
NOW. IT'S UP TO BE VERY HONEST
WITH YOU. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN CONNECT DOCKS, BUT
YOU SEE LIKE, SAY
SOMEBODY A VETERAN LIKE COAL
BEASLEY SUDDENLY MIGHT NOT BE
BACK WITH THE BILLS,
WRITE A HEADLINE THAT JUST
POPPED IN THE LAST
HALF HOUR.
I MEAN, IF YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND GRAB THE
KID
IN THE FOURTH OR FIFTH ROUND.
I THINK HE CAN ACTUALLY START
TO YOUR TEAM.
THAT'S WHAT I SAW LAST NIGHT.
AND THEN THE QUARTERBACK SPOT.
I MEAN, MALIK WILL HAS HAD ME
AT HELLO.
HE'S GOT A BIG ARM.
HE'S GOT SOME BIG GAME.
AND
AS I TWEETED OUT LAST NIGHT,
EVEN DURING THE BROADCAST,
IF I'M A STEELERS FAN, I'M
LIKE, YES, PLEASE
THE RESPONSE. I GOT FROM STEVE
SMITH ON THE TURF AND THEN OF
COURSE, THROUGH SOME OTHER
PEOPLE ON TWITTER WAS
LIKE,
HOW DO YOU KNOW HE'S GONNA BE
THERE? 20.
I MEAN,
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GET
PUSHED UP AND HE MIGHT EVEN BE
THE FIRST GUY OFF THE BOARD.
YEAH, THERE'S A LOT OF HYPE
THAT COMES INTO IT AND I
ALWAYS KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
BE THE CASE, RIGHT?
ANY TIME BETWEEN WHEN THE
SUPER BOWL ENDS TO WHEN THE
COMBINE HAPPENS AND THEN
ULTIMATELY THE DRAFT
THE SPIN, THE HYPE TRAIN,
ALL OF IT PLAYS INTO THE
QUARTERBACKS ADVANTAGE AND
ULTIMATELY THERE'S GOING TO BE
GENERAL MANAGERS OUT THERE
THAT FEAR,
YOU'RE GOING TO MISS OUT ON
THE NEXT GREAT QUARTERBACK
AND THEY'LL DO AND MOVE,
HEAVEN, AND EARTH TO GO GET
THAT.
YEAH, AND AND YOU KNOW,
HE'S GOT HE'S GOT
A LOT OF THE IT FACTOR. I KNEW
I KNOW
YOU KNOW,
FACT THAT HE PLAYED AT LIBERTY
MEANS, NOT MANY PEOPLE SAW HIM
AUBURN, HE WAS IN AUBURN.
KID. HE WAS AN AUBURN KID
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS AND
WHEN AUBURN WENT TO
BONE X AFTER STIDHAM LEFT,
THAT'S WHEN HE
TRANSFERRED
AND HE'S GOT BIG GAME
MEN.
I SAW HIM.
BUT JASMINE RITTER HAD A NICE
NIGHT LAST NIGHT, BUT AGAIN,
SITTING THERE AND,
YOU KNOW, WORKOUT CLOTHES AND
THERE'S REALLY NO
ADVERSITY OTHER THAN THE FACT.
THAT YOU'VE BEEN POKED AND
PRODDED FOR THREE AND A HALF
DAYS BEFOREHAND AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO GET OUT ON THE
FIELD. IT'S JUST NOT A REALLY,
YOU KNOW,
AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE LOVE
THEIR PRO DAYS A LITTLE BIT
BETTER
THAT YOU DON'T GO THROUGH THE
GAUNTLET OF THE MEDICAL AND
AND THE
LOGICAL THE INTERVIEWS. I
MEAN, IT REALLY IS.
I MEAN,
THIS IS JUST THE
THE END OF THE COMBINE OR
DONE,
AND THERE'S A RELIEF WHEN
YOU'RE DONE WITH IT, BUT IT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART OF IT
BECAUSE IT IS THE PHYSICAL.
YOU KNOW,
ATTRIBUTES THAT GOT MANY OF
THESE KIDS
TO THE INVITATION OF THE
COMBINE.
SO OUTSIDE OF ALL THAT YOU
LIKE, YOU JUST DON'T KNOW.
IT'S JUST PART OF A PUZZLE.
THE PIECE OF PUZZLE YOU THAT
ALL THE TIME,
BUT
THIS DRAFT TONIGHT. I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
MAYBE THE FIRST OVERALL PICK
OUT THERE WITH ONE OF THE
OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
WAY IT'S GOING
TO GO. AND I KNOW
THAT
LAST YEAR THERE WERE ONLY
THREE
QUARTERBACKS TAKEN IN THE
FIRST THREE PICKS.
WE MAY NOT SEE ONE OF THE TOP
OFFENSIVE EAR
LINEMEN DEFENSIVE LINEMAN AND
MAYBE ONE OF THE OHIO STATE
WIDE RECEIVERS, WHICH
WHICHEVER ONE YOU LIKE
SPEAKING OF THOSE WIDE
RECEIVERS, RIGHT? CRYSTAL AVE
RAN A
UNOFFICIAL AND THEN WE SAW TAE
KWON THORNTON AT THE
WIDE RECEIVER POSITION. RUN
THE
FOUR TO ONE THAT LOOKED LIKE
IT BROKE THE RECORD. WHAT WAS
YOUR IMPRESSION THERE WHEN
THAT HAPPENS? BECAUSE
BROCKMAN AND I WERE TALKING
TALKING ABOUT THIS, RIGHT? THE
FACT THEY GO AND RUN IT AND
IT'S A DROP THE MIC MOMENT.
LIKE I JUST BROKE THE RECORD
THAT'S OUT THERE. I KNOW IT'S,
I KNOW THEY SAY UNOFFICIAL,
BUT WHATEVER. I'M NOT GOING TO
RUN A SECOND TIME AND THEN AN
HOUR LATER
SEVEN AND ONE HUNDREDS OF A
SECOND OFF.
RUNNING A FOR 39 AND WE DIDN'T
GET THOSE TIMES UNTIL DJ,
AND I'VE
GANGA MINOR, I WERE WALKING
BACK TO THE HOTEL. YEAH.
WE STAYED ON A HALF AN HOUR
AFTER THE
ON-FIELD DRILLS WERE DONE
AND WE'RE LIKE, IF A
LOBBY HAD KNOWN THAT,
THANK YOU, WOULD HAVE JUST
RESTED AND ON HIS
LAWS AND WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU
WOULD HAVE? MADE ME RUN IT
AGAIN.
AND YOU KNOW,
THE ANSWER IS MAYBE BUT
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY IT
AGAIN,
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HIM
RUNNING A
FOUR TO EIGHT AND A 439
WITH THE
CLEAR
HIGH IN THE SKY
TAPE.
ALL RIGHT ON HIM.
I HONESTLY DON'T THINK IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AS TO
WHETHER SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
DRAFT THEM IN THIS
SPOT OR THAT.
SPOT. I MEAN THE 439
JUST SHOWS. HE'S FAST AND
HE'S FAST. HE'S CAPABLE
OF INCREDIBLE.
NOW. IT'S FOR SOMEBODY LIKE,
YOU KNOW THE KID FROM BAYLOR
WHO WE SAW FOUR TO ONE AND
LOOK WE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED LAST NIGHT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU BECAUSE
WE WE HAD A
SIMULCRAM
ALL SET UP
FOR
OLAVE
AND TERRY MCLAREN
WHO RAN A 435
AND
YOU KNOW, AND WE SAW
ON THE
SIMULCAST AM THAT MCLAREN.
BO LA BE MORE LIKE, OKAY, SO
THAT'S WHY WE SAY THESE TIMES
ARE UNOFFICIAL, RIGHT? YOU
KNOW,
LIKE WHEN WE SAY, WE MEAN IT
NOW THE YELLOW LINE DURING AN
NFL GAME.
YEAH. IT'S PRETTY OFFICIAL.
BUT I MEAN,
THESE TIMES ARE TRULY
UNOFFICIAL WHERE
THEIR STARTED WITH A HAND TIME
AND THEN YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY
IT'S A BUTTON
ONCE THE KID IS OFF AND
RUNNING
AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO MATCH UP
WITH THE
ELECTRONIC TIME. THAT'S
THE FIRST MOVEMENT. IT'S
SUPPOSED TO GO.
GO.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
THE BACK ELECTRONIC OR IN CASE
GOES DOWN, THEN WE
USE THAT.
BUT THE ELECTRONIC WAS OFF
LAST NIGHT. THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT AND
HOPEFULLY, THEY'LL GET IT
FIXED FOR TONIGHT. YEAH. WELL,
WE BETTER HOPE THAT
ELECTRONICS ARE OFF FOR YOU.
MAYBE WE CAN GET IT UNDER 60 5
WHEN YOU RUN IT HERE IN ABOUT
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, IN A FEW
WEEKS
IN LOS ANGELES, JUST LIKE I
DID LAST YEAR AND EVERYONE WAS
LIKE YOU SHOULD GET OUT THERE
BECAUSE IT LOOKED
A FAST TRACK LIKE THIS A FAST
TRACK LAST NIGHT.
YEAH, WHAT ARE THOSE? ONE OF
THE COOLER THINGS
GIOVANNI IN THE
BOOTH WITH YOU AND DJ
TALK OF US, TALK TO US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT AND HOW
MUCH FUN YOU HAD
WITH THAT EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW,
HIS DAD GOT A JOB OUT HERE
AND IT'S INTERESTING ENOUGH
HAPPENED. JUST AS HIS FAVORITE
EAGLE CARSON, WENTZ CAME OUT
HERE TO. AND SO
HE HAD TICKETS TO THE COMBINE.
I SAW IT ON TWITTER AND
AND YOU KNOW
AS SOON AS HE
IT OUT, AM GOING TO COMBINE,
YOU KNOW, THE NFL NETWORK
DID.
IT'S DUE DILIGENCE AND
AND IT WAS PRETTY COOL.
HE'S A SWEET KID. I'VE BEEN ON
HIS SHOW.
LIVES OUT HERE IN THE MIDWEST.
HE STILL HAS HIS PHILLY ROOTS
WHEN I ASKED
THEM, YOU KNOW, HEY,
HOWIE ROSAMOND MIGHT BE
LISTENING TO YOU RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WOULD YOUR MESSAGE BE TO
HOWIE DRAFT, THIS WIDE L,
RECEIVERS. AND FOR THE LOVE OF
GOD, GET US
LINEBACKERS.
IT'S WHAT HE SAID.
FOR THE LOVE OF GOD,
YOU KNOW, AND
IT WAS FANTASTIC
AND HE DID MEET ROSEMOND AND
SURIANI LATER. AND THEN HE
WENT OUT
AFTER HE WAS DONE IN THE
BOOTH. HE WENT AND HUNG OUT ON
THE DIGITAL.
BROADCAST WITH COLLEEN WOLF,
WHO WAS YOU KNOW, IS
STILL HE'S THROUGH AND
THROUGH. SO IT WAS REALLY
SWEET AND YOU KNOW, THERE'S SO
MUCH CRAP
AND AWFULNESS GOING ON IN OUR
WORLD
THAT
TO SEE A KID WHO LOVES
THE GAME
AND AND LOVES TALKING ABOUT
THE GAME.
JUST BEING
HERE AND THEN HANGING OUT WITH
US, YOU KNOW, TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT. SO
THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
GRADY CHANCE TO MEET HIM.
HE DOES LOVE THE GAME. HE DOES
KNOW THE GAME. HE'S
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE DIG HIM.
YEAH. BECAUSE THEY JUST THEY
FEEL HIS WARMTH IN HIS
ESSENCE AND I'M GLAD HE WAS ON
THE NETWORK LAST NIGHT. WELL,
IT WAS REALLY FUN TO SEE AND
I, AND IT JUST FROM
SOMEBODY WAS VIEWING. IT, YOU
JUST THE EXPRESSION ON BOTH
YOURS AND
DJ'S FACE, HAS MADE IT. I MEAN
THAT EVEN MAKES IT YOU JUST
WERE ENJOYING YOURSELF SO MUCH
AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY MEANINGFUL
TO SEE THAT COMING FROM YOU
BEAUTIFUL.
DID YOU SEE THE
MUSIC THAT I WAS TELLING YOU
ABOUT? DID YOU HEAR THE MUSIC?
I WAS TELLING YOU ABOUT IN THE
FIRST PART. NOW YOU SAID YOU
WOULD BE THE SOUND LIKE DOWN.
BUT YEAH.
ON? YOU SAID IT GOT SHUT DOWN
ALL RICH.
OH, YEAH. YEAH. OH, YEAH.
MUSIC THE MUSIC
GOT SHUT DOWN
AS I SAID DURING THE BROADCAST
LAST NIGHT.
I ASKED, DANIEL JEREMIAH. WHAT
WAS IT? WHAT WAS A SHORTER
TENURE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
THE MUSIC AT THE COMBINE OR
BILL, BELICHICK IS THE HEAD
COACH OF THE JETS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
AIR LAST NIGHT.
WHAT WAS THE WHAT WAS THE
REASON YOU STARTED PLAYING?
YOU COULD JUST SEE THE
SCOUTS IN THE STANDS, KIND OF
LOOK AT EACH OTHER,
LIKE WHO, WHO
LEFT THE RADIO ON, YOU KNOW,
LIKE WHAT'S GOING ON?
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY GOT THAT
MUCH OF A HEADS UP. THERE WERE
10,000 FANS THERE LAST NIGHT.
SO I GUESS THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE
FOR THE RIGHT.
AND AND AND SO THEY'VE STARTED
PLAYING MUSIC.
THE PROBLEM IS THE MUSIC WAS
KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
IT WAS INTRUSIVE IN THE
FACT THAT
FOR INSTANCE,
THAT THEY ANNOUNCED THEY
ANNOUNCED ON A
LOUDSPEAKER WHO'S RUNNING
WHO'S NOT WHO'S RUNNING
BECAUSE
IF THEY HAVE A MEDICAL ISSUE
AND WHO'S NOT RUNNING BECAUSE
THEY JUST
DON'T WANNA AND THAT
THEY'LL RUN AT THE PRO DAY AND
THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE MADE
CERTAINLY, THE MORE IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENTS BEING,
YOU KNOW,
WHO'S RUNNING A SECOND
SECOND TIME.
SO LIKE FOR INSTANCE, WHEN
OLAVE DOESN'T RUN A SECOND
TIME, THEY ANNOUNCED
LIKE, YOU KNOW, CHRIS OLAVE.
ESSENTIALLY
IS ELECTS TO, YOU KNOW, NOT
RUNNING IT
RIGHT
OR,
YOU KNOW, MALIK WILLIS IS NOT
RUNNING, YOU KNOW, HE'LL RUN
IT. IT'S PRO DAY LIKE THEY
LITERALLY MAKE THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS
FOOD. THE ANNOUNCEMENT, HERE,
THOSE THINGS,
YOU KNOW,
SO
THERE WERE, YOU KNOW,
SOME SOME MESSAGES
THAT WERE KIND OF SENT UP THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND.
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
IT WAS QUIET AS A CHURCH IN
THERE. I GOT TO PUSH IT BACK
ON THIS WHICH I KNOW YOU WERE
KIND OF YOU KNOW SAID IT WAS
WACK BUT LIKE
THESE SCOUTS
IT'S NOT FOR THEM. OKAY.
IT'S A TELEVISION
EVENT FOR FANS
AND
IT'S TURNING INTO
THIS BIG TYPE OF TENT
TENT, POLE OFF SEASON EVENT OF
AS WE HEAD INTO THE DRAFT,
WRITE THE EVALUATION
PERIOD. OKAY, WE CAN
SET UP SOME KIND OF
TEXT.
VEZ
FOR THE
SCOUTS IF THEY REALLY WANT TO
KNOW, IF A GUY ISN'T GOING TO
RUN A SECOND TIME
LIKE SOMEONE WITH THE NFL, CAN
GET EVERYONE'S
PHONE NUMBERS ON A FILE AND
HIT ONE BIG GROUP
TAX AND CRYSTAL AVE WILL NOT
BE RUNNING A SECOND GRADE.
EVERYONE'S GOT THEIR PHONE ON
PEOPLE, EVEN KEEP THE MUSIC ON
IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
10,000 FANS THERE AND MAKE
THIS INTO THIS BIG
THING, LIKE
THE SCOUTS HAVE TO TAKE A BACK
SEAT. I'M SORRY. YEAH, BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS THING IS.
THIS IS
NEW. IT IS
FOR THE SCOUTS, CHRIS. THIS IS
LITERALLY WHAT ARE THE PRO
DAYS FOR
A GOOD? ONE OF THE OTHER ONE
OF THE OTHER THE PRO DAYS,
OUR FIRST INITIALLY, FOR
OTHER SCOUTS THAT
ARE IN THE AREA OR KIDS
THAT WERE NOT INVITED TO THE
COMBINE LIKE NOT EVERY
KID IS THAT THERE'S ONLY
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY-FIVE
INVITES TO THIS DAY
IF I'M A PLAYER, IF I'M
IF I'M THE PLAYERS NEXT YEAR,
I'M SAYING I'M NOT I'M NOT I'M
NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON THIS
MUSICS ROCKING THAT'S THAT'S
THE DEAL
325 INVITES TO THIS DAY. IF
I'M A PLAYER IF I'M IF I'M THE
PLAYERS NEXT YEAR I'M SAYING
I'M NOT I'M NOT I'M NOT GOING
YOU KNOW WHAT? I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE HILL. THEY WANT TO
DIE ON
US LIKE THIS. LIKE FOR
INSTANCE, GEORGIA HAS THE MOST
KIDS HERE, BUT NOT ALL
THE KIDS HERE,
YOU KNOW. YEAH. AND THEN
AND THEN THERE MIGHT BE SOME
SMALL
SCHOOLS AROUND,
GEORGIA AROUND ATHENS THAT
MIGHT SEND SOME
KID THERE. SO IT'S JUST
ANOTHER WAY
PRO DAYS ARE JUST ANOTHER WAY
BOOK.
THE COMBINE IS,
ESSENTIALLY THE REASON WHY IT
EXISTS IN. THE REASON WHY IT
WILL ALWAYS EXIST IS
FOR THE
MEDICAL.
SHE'S RIGHT. AND FOR SOME OF
THE
FACE TO FACE INTERVIEWS,
EXACTLY, WHILE WE'RE AT IT
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT, DOING
ALL OF THESE ON-FIELD DRILLS
WHILE
EVERYBODY'S THERE.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY IT WAS
CREATED.
SO NOW, THE FACT THAT THE
OURSELVES COMING IN WITH SOME
FANS
AND TRYING TO MAKE IT A FAN
IT STILL SHOULDN'T IT STILL
DOESN'T INTRUDE ON WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT, WHICH IS THE
ON-FIELD DRILLS AND THE
MEDICAL
EVALUATIONS, AND THE NFL
NETWORK ITSELF
HAS BEEN MADE.
MAKING,
YOU KNOW, A DANCE AROUND
THAT
FOR 17, 18 YEARS,
SO YOU CAN'T ASK EVERYONE
ELSE TO ADAPT AND THEN THE
SCOUTS JUST TO GO GO ABOUT
BUSINESS AS USUAL. LIKE THEY
HAVE BEEN FOR THE LAST 30
YEARS, LIKE THEY HAVE TO ADAPT
AS WELL. AND IF IT MEANS LIKE
PUTTING IN SOME,
YOU KNOW,
SOME BUDS TOO, SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HEAR THE MUSIC'S AND
SO BE IT.
WELL, IT'S KIND OF LIKE CHRIS.
LIKE LET'S JUST PUT IT THIS
WAY.
YOU KNOW, LET'S JUST SAY
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING A
CERTAIN WAY
FOR A VERY
LONG TIME AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
BROADEN THINGS OUT
FOR OTHERS OR PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING IN TO TRY AND BROADEN
IT OUT FOR OTHERS. LET'S SAY
YOUR BURGER DRAFT,
RIGHT? YOU WANT TO GET MORE
PEOPLE.
IF YOUR BURGER DRAFT AND
YOU'RE GOING TO ALLOW
COUPLE OF PEOPLE
TO EAT WHATEVER THEY WANT.
BECAUSE OTHER THAN THAT,
YOU KNOW, OTHER THAN THAT
THAN THEY WON'T ATTACK, RIGHT?
LET'S JUST SAY YOU'RE TRYING
TO EXPAND
YOUR
YOUR, YOUR AUDIENCE FOR IT,
RIGHT? YOU'LL STILL BE
STAYING.
SCREW THAT.
RIGHT?
YOU COME HERE.
ONLY WHAT EAT
BURGER IS DRAFTED FOR YOU,
RIGHT? WHEN YOU SAY THAT
BUT IF I WANT TO PLAY MUSIC
AND YOU WANT TO
AND THEY'RE LIKE
TURN THE MUSIC
OFF.
YOU DON'T EVEN LOSE IT WHILE
WE DON'T HAVE A TECH SYSTEM
SET UP.
I WILL SAY THIS THOUGH.
FANS WERE FUN.
IN THE FACT THAT
ANYTHING WHEN DAVID BELL,
BY THE WAY,
WE NAILED THE GLUE, GUYS.
KNOW WE WE NAIL. I MEAN WE
WERE ON IT.
LAST NIGHT ALONE
AND SO IN DAVID BELL,
HIGH SCHOOL, 12 MILES DOWN THE
ROAD
WHEN HE DID ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WAS LOUD. YEAH.
FANS WERE CHEERING. THEY WERE
LIKE CLASS. NEVER HEARD
BEFORE
DAVID
BELLE GOES THROUGH THE
GAUNTLET DRILL.
HE'S
DONE WITH IT.
THAT'S AWESOME. SO, WEIRD NOW
SCOUTS YOU GET USED TO THAT
BECAUSE IT'S JUST APPLAUSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I MEAN? LIKE
THAT'S THAT'S ONE THING AND
ALL LIKE
ANY TIME THERE WERE LIKE TEN,
DUDES, DRUNK DUDES, LIKE
PROBABLY FROM LIKE COLUMBUS,
ANYTIME OLAVE AND GARRETT
WILSON DID ANYTHING AND THIS
IS LATE AT NIGHT, WHEN HALF
THE CROWD WAS GONE.
THEY WERE GOING APE
AND THEY
DIDN'T AND NOT IN THE EYE AND
THE
STANDS.
YEAH, IT'S BEEN WHEN THEY WERE
QUARTERBACKS AND YOUR GUYS
STRONG FROM NEVADA,
MALIK WILLIS AND WHOEVER
COULD REALLY
CRANK IT
AND THROW IT, DOWNFIELD,
60 YARDS IN THE AIR
AND THEN THEY COMPLETED IT.
EVERYBODY WENT CRAZY
AND THAT WAS FUN. LIKE THERE
WAS ACTUALLY ENERGY IN THE
BUILDING FOR
THAT.
AND I HOPE, YOU KNOW, SCOUTS
OR WHOMEVER DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT,
BUT
WHAT'S THE MUSIC
SUCKED? I DON'T KNOW WHO CHOSE
IT REALLY WASN'T
IT'S LIKE STUCK IN THE LARGEST
ELEVATOR EVER.
IT'S REALLY NOT.
ALL AROUND.
WAS CLEARLY, CLEARLY. THE
PLAYERS DIDN'T CHOOSE THE
MUSIC, RIGHT? HERE'S THE MOVE
NEXT YEAR.
NEXT YEAR, WHEN THE
QUARTERBACKS ARE THROWING
LET THE QUARTERBACK, WHO'S
THROWING HAVE CONTROL
OF THE PLAYLIST?
JUST KIND OF LIKE THE WALKOUT
MUSIC
OH, GOSH,
I DON'T I DON'T DON'T KNOW IF
EVERYONE WAS ON THE SAME PAGE
GOING IN. YEAH, BUT I'LL TELL
YOU WHAT, THEY CERTAINLY RIP
THAT PAGE OUT OF THE BOOK AND
IN A HURRY
IN A HURRY. HEY.
HEY, I WANT TO I WANT TO I
WANT TO TALK INTO ONE THING
I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE YOU RST
KNOW, THE KENNY PICKET NEWS.
IT WAS JUST A PUNCH LINE ALL
DAY LONG, RIGHT?
EIGHT-AND-A-HALF?
ENHANCE THESE TINY HANDS, HOW
CAN YOU EVEN FUNCTION AS A
PLAYER?
ALL THESE THINGS? RIGHT? AND
THEN NFL NETWORK, RIGHT?
WRITE IT RIGHT THERE,
CAMERAMAN, RIGHT?
NEXT TO HIM. HE'S NOT HE'S NOT
OBLIVIOUS TO THE GUY,
YOU KNOW, FILMING HIS HANDS
AND NOT HIS BODY OR HIS FACE.
IT'S LOOKING RIGHT AT HIS
HANDS AND THEN HE GOES OUT AND
ANYBODY LAST NIGHT. HE WAS  AS
COMPACT. HE WAS ACCURATE. HE
WAS FLUID AND EVERYTHING. HE
TELL US TALK TO US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT. AND HOW DO YOU
THINK HIS PERFORMANCE CAME OUT
HANDS THAT SOMETHING HE CAN'T
CONTROL?
OH, YEAH. I MEAN HE'S GONNA
YOU'LL BE A FIRST-ROUND
QUARTERBACK. NO DOUBT. I MEAN,
THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT
HE'LL GO IN THE FIRST
DJ DANIEL SAID THAT, YOU
KNOW, THERE WILL BE SOME
TEAMS THAT WILL LITERALLY TAKE
THEM OFF THEIR BOARDS BECAUSE
HE'S ONLY GOT EIGHT AND A HALF
INCH HANDS AND
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WOULD BE
SUCH A PROBLEM. I MEAN, THE
GUY WEARS GLOVES FOR
A REASON. I THINK HE GETS A
NICE GRIP ON IT. KURT WARNER
WAS ON THE FIELD.
HE WAS MR. WEARING GLOVES AND
DUMPED HIS ENTIRE CAREER
BETTER.
GRAB MY MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
KID, RAN,
IT RAMPS UP, 47.
I MEAN, HE'S REALLY ATHLETIC
AND HE'S TALL, AND HE'S
GOOD.
AND HE'S DONE IT IN
PITTSBURGH. SO,
YOU KNOW, AS I SAID ON THE
SHOW YESTERDAY, DESMOND,
RAIDERS GOT 10 PLUS INCH HANDS
AND FUMBLED IT OVER 30 TIMES
IN CINCINNATI, SO
I DON'T KNOW, YOU TELL ME
I THOUGHT HE WAS. YEAH. I JUST
THOUGHT HE WAS GREAT LAST
NIGHT. GOOD.
YEAH, YOU LOOK GOOD. THERE'S
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT. ALL
RIGHT,
ONE THING OUTSIDE. THE COMBINE
PURVIEW THE CONVERSATION AND
ADAM SCHEFTER REPORTING THAT
AMARI COOPER
THERE IN DALLAS
MAY BE RELEASED BEFORE THE
LEAGUE.
START YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
AND
WHAT THAT ACCOMPLISHES FOR THE
DALLAS COWBOYS.
WELL, I MEAN LOOK, WHEN, WHEN
SIGNED COOPER, AND AND
DEKE AND KNOWING THAT GOD WAS
GOING TO GET HIS MONEY AND
THEN HE DID. I MEAN,
HOW MANY TEAMS CAN HAVE A
QUARTERBACK RUNNING BACK WIDE
RECEIVER COMBINATION COUNT FOR
WHAT?
LIKE
70 MILLION ON ON YOUR CAT?
I MEAN, NO MATTER HOW
LARGE YOUR,
YOUR THE CAP NUMBER KEEPS
GOING UP BY IT, WHATEVER
MARGIN. I MEAN,
AT SOME POINT THAT'S JUST NOT
SUSTAINABLE
AND THE FACT THAT ZEKE STILL
AROUND IS KIND OF AMAZING
BECAUSE YOU THINK THE RUNNING
BACK
WOULD BE THE ONE WITH
THE QUICKEST EXPIRATION DATE,
BUT IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT
AMARI COOPER WAS NO LONGER,
YOU KNOW, THE NUMBER ONE
TARGET IN THE OFFENSE LAST
YEAR, THAT IT WAS CD LAMB.
SEAL, AM 100%.
YOU KNOW, THE FACT THAT I'M
ALREADY COOPER WOULD
ESSENTIALLY HAVE TO SPEAK UP,
WHICH SHE NEVER DOES.
AND
YOU KNOW
TO SAY HEY, I'M STILL HERE.
DEFINITELY WAS ODD
TO SAY THE LEAST.
AND AGAIN, I JUST SAW THOSE
KIDS LAST NIGHT AT THE WIDE
RECEIVER POSITION.
I MEAN, WHY WOULD YOU,
YOU KNOW, I DO PAY
REPLICA. HE'S STILL VERY
YOUNG,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
20 MILLION DOLLAR, HIT OF SOME
SORT,
OR CLOSE TO IT. I'D IMAGINE. I
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT YOU SIGN AGAIN. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT PHONY MONEY
WAS IN IT, OR WHAT HE WOULD
COUNT FOR THIS YEAR OR
HAVING A 16
MILLION. I THINK IT'S
POCKET CHANGE. YEAH,  YOUR
HUGE CHUNK OF CHANGE, YOU KNOW
THAT GALLUP IS HURT AND
BUT THAT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
IT JUST DOESN'T. AND THEN THE
FACT THAT HE WAS ONE OF THEIR
STILL ON THE TEAM LAST YEAR. I
THINK REALLY RANKLES.
THE JONESES AND IT'S
PROTOCOLS. YESTERDAY OVID
WERE WERE WERE SHELVED AND,
BUT STILL WHAT WILL LINGER
IS SOMEBODY AT A TIME
WHEN ALL THEY HAD TO DO WAS
TAKE A SHOT
AND THAT WOULD GIVE THEM A
BETTER CHANCE TO WIN. AND THEY
DID NOT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WILL LINGER IN THE MIND'S EYE
OF
THE FRONT OFFICES AND
OWNERSHIP AND I THINK YOU PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER. AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
COOPER WILL BE ON ANOTHER
TEAM.
AND YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY THERE
WILL BE SOME
TEAMS THAT WILL JUMP ALL OVER
HIM. CERTAINLY WHEN
YOU GOT TO START FROM SCRATCH
ON HIS CONTRACT,
BUT IT DIDN'T REALLY SURPRISE
ME HEAR THAT. TODAY. WE DID A
MOST LIKELY WITH WITH
CHRIS BROCKMAN TODAY, AND HE
PRACTICED ONE OF THESE
FOR FOR OUR
FRIEND HERE, TJ.
PERSON IS IT MOST LIKELY THAT
THE DALLAS COWBOYS
PLAY IN THE SUPER BOWL OR THAT
RICH WHO PLAYS IN
OUR FIRST COWBOYS ARE AMARI
COOPER?
OH, THAT'S A GOOD ONE. HOW IS
THAT? HOW DO YOU ANSWER?
WELL, OF COURSE TJ WAS WAS
OF COWBOYS, BUT US
THE REAL WORLD SAID AMARI
COOPER BECAUSE I'LL PROBABLY
END UP WITH THE CHIEFS FOR THE
RAMS OF THE PATRIOTS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
COULD YOU IMAGINE HIM ON THE
CHIEFS? I MEAN, HE ALWAYS SO I
SAID THAT
THE RAIDERS AGAINST THE
CHIEFS, YOU HAD TO PICK A
COUPLE OF
A COUPLE OF 200 YARD GAMES
200 YARD GAMES AGAINST THEM.
YEAH,
SO I'LL TAKE WHAT'S MORE
LIKELY COOPER ELSEWHERE RATHER
THAN DALLAS
WITHOUT
HIM.
ALL RIGHT. RICH
RICH
WITH AS ALWAYS. THANKS SO MUCH
FOR TAKING TIME OUT TO HELP US
OUT.
APPRECIATE YOU FOR THE TRUST.
AGAIN, WITH THE, WITH YOUR
PLATFORM. IT'S BEEN AMAZING
THREE DAYS. SO YOU ENJOY YOUR
REST OF THE TRIP,
AND I'LL SEE YOU SOON.
YOU GOT IT. I'M AT 4:00
EASTERN TODAY, TOMORROW. AND
THEN
TO EASTERN ON SUNDAY, AND THEN
BACK IN THAT CHAIR ON MONDAY.
ALL RIGHT. WELL,
NOBODY HAS
ANY WARM FOR YOU.
TAKE IT EASY, GUYS,
SIGHS. AND FROM THE RICH EISEN
SHOW
JOINING US FROM INDIANAPOLIS.